Beauty Tycoon Huda Katan faces Furious
backlash and boycott threats to her
makeup line after sharing anti-israel
video on Instagram I don't know who this
is do you guys know who Huda Katan is
yeah she has a really popular makeup
line especially when this this will mean
nothing to the boys in the room but you
might get it uh baking which is where
you put a lot of like setting powder
under your eyes and then brush it off
she was one of the had a really popular
product for that and she's carried in
Sephora Ulta things like that um she she
gotten in trouble for similar things
before but obviously now the timing
makes everyone's moves more heightened
um I know people often say you know you
should you should cancel her and they do
this with other makeup companies so
another one was Anastasia Beverly Hills
apparently the founder had some
pro-russian statements when there the
Ukraine stuff was happening so they have
great products what everyone needs to
understand here is that this uh this
famous celebrity woman who sells makeup
is willing to burn everything down
around her to support Gaza
good for her and people on the right are
too busy saying I can't speak up no I
can't take the risk sorry oh but you
know it's just it's it's you know I
can't do it there you go so long as
that's the case they're going to they're
going to continually gain ground now to
be fair for for a variety of reasons I
think this is actually like my my point
here is about the conviction of the left
their willingness to destroy everything
to get what they want people have to
take risks you have to be able to be a
political risk taker but being said I
think she'll just end up losing a ton of
money and her her brain will start
fizzling she might or this might blow
over in a week honestly that's what
happens in the past she because she's
she's a US Iraqi Citizen and she said
stuff that people get upset about but
the boycotts never last as long as she
has ownership of her company Kat Von D
got in trouble for saying some uh very
not PC things uh having some strange um
marketing for her cosmetics and she
ended up getting she sold her company
but she was almost pushed out was that
was recently though right like not that
long ago a couple years ago years ago I
think she just got baptized whoa really
she had a huge she's on an arc right now
we actually just talked about this
todaying she got b a couple weeks ago
yeah amazing to watch her get her
tattoos blacked out and to be for
medical freedom and move to where is she
Ohio
Ohio he's been um
I follow all these guys because I have a
Cosmetics line too but get this you do I
do it's called bonaa Cosmetics no way
absolutely gu on Public Square so I'm in
pre-production I've been in
pre-production since May what made you
want to do this I made it for real women
by
women actual women if you catch my drift
yeah I get you the whole was there a a
Sephora just wasn't there SE like
somebody who's like a Maga supporter who
was like Sephora or Ulta and she was
like sponsored by them and they got rid
of her because of stuff she said like
did a video like with prageru or
something like a year ago I wouldn't be
surprised but I don't know that story
specifically I mean Ulta was one of the
big um Dylan
Mulan girlhood podcast so I basically
started a Cosmetics line to push back
against it and said we're only using
real women as makeup models no deal in M
people were very offended they were like
what about your transf I was like well
I'm not upset with them you know but we
have to push the Overton window in a
certain direction and so this is the
stand that I'm taking we're going to
make women's products I'm coming up with
tampons and things like that too it's
crazy how now like you have to like it's
all whataboutism like Victoria Secret
like Victoria Secret saying like they're
like you need to have people who aren't
super hot too they're like why can't
they why can't you just be like no we
don't like you can do that we don't we
don't need to do that let's just have
young attractive models showing off
products and and that's okay hasn't made
them feel guilty about that they don't
feel like they can do that anymore now
to be fair a lot of their models are
underage and I think they should not do
that no no no we should have people in
their you know 18 in their 20s showing
off products and making products look
appealing and nice I think that's good
marketing sure sure what I'm saying is
there a lot of people don't realize when
they go to the mall and they're walking
past these mall stores with these women
those women are like 15 years old girls
are I worked as a as a gene model
briefly when I was like you know 181 19
and most of the competition was like 15
to 17 that's messed up it's just weird
was it Victoria secet I mean it's like
when when when they're doing La under
stuff it is everywhere it is everywhere
it is the biggest it is the major the
major agencies the international
agencies they get 14 15y old girls to do
underwear modeling it's it's it's it's
messed up they shouldn't do that it's
worldwide okay so last thing about
makeup which you'll find interesting the
reason I've had production delays is
because every company that I start to
purchase materials from instead of
coming from Canada it all comes from
China and I even busted them on the
tracking they were so bold as to issue
me a tracking label where it was coming
from Beijing I was like why is this
taking so long why is this taking so
long so we're on our third round right
now do you are you okay with it being
produced in China I was trying to find
something produced in Canada the United
States just not China yeah and they were
like no to the point of the article
though now like celebrities are having a
a really hard time not talking about
stuff like this and there's just so many
of them I'm like you would do so well to
just not you don't have to have a stance
on everything was it Alicia Keys yes she
said she wanted to go paragliding like I
have no I have no idea what her politics
are if that's true or not if that is
like a coincidence it's the worst
coincidence she posted on Instagram what
would you do if you weren't afraid I'd
try paragliding and then she posted the
side eye emoji oh my God which like the
side eye emoji makes it what she saying
we should not kill people why should but
then but then she responds with like an
Instagram story she's like oh I didn't
mean that like I pray for this girl was
testing the water she wanted to see what
would happen and that's it because we
know that there are a lot of young more
radical left Ling people who are backing
Palestine in this and that's what she's
doing she's seeing resp and we know
black lives matter foundationally wants
to end Israel other people they align
themselves with are are falling onto
certain sides I mean with Huda Beauty I
wouldn't be surprised if now you get a
whole wave of young women who are like
I'm specifically buying her products
because I also believe in that that's
the thing about all virtue signaling is
that really bigger than just a large
Market especially if you're already
established right does does Alicia Keys
benefit does her music benefit from
making to make a post like that when
you're already mainstream
out of what's Taylor doing she has the
best marketing she is just dating a
football player and staying in her Lan
does drink Bud Light and is uh sponsored
by fizer but to what you said earlier
like what you were talking ear like all
the news is like crap and it's it's it's
war and it's death and I was like no
because there was like a really funny
article the other day where some poor
People magazine person had to write a
headline said like Taylor Swift has now
held Travis Kel's hand twice in public
some poor lady had to write that it's
like we're in middle school I saw that
post and then immed mediately messaged
on Instagram to some of my friends that
I went to see Taylor Swift with being
like they're holding hands she got she
got four years in J School $80,000 in
debt and they're like wow holding hands
twice right it up it's like we've now
gone like like like the amount like time
you have to spend talking about her
because like every institution and every
business has tried to like weasle their
way into her life no one more rentree in
everyone's head Taylor Swift yeah I'm
not I'm not a fan but man I wish the
news was consumed with Taylor Swift and
not dying in
isra all domestic issues are I don't I
don't understand why look when I see the
Taylor Swift hate I'm like it's fake
like dude you have no re no there's no
reason to hate her like I I oh for sure
yeah it's just like people ragging on
her and I'm like she's a pop star like
she's dancing on stage I saw someone
saying that that she must be doing
horribly if she was dating a
professional athlete no everyone else is
like I'm super I'm super her tour is
like it's like a mass 2.2 billion
already made some ridiculous amount of
money like Taylor is doing fine aspire
to be on her level of calm right now and
like people are like you guys have you
guys keep talking about her like we
don't I don't want to I have no desire
to talk about her but she's relevant in
almost every like how old how old is she
she's 33 33 I'm very interested in her
marketing follow that pretty closely oh
no that's that's the thing that they
already she's eligible in 2024 she'll be
she would be 35 on a on inauguration day
stay out of inauguration day oh so
January January 20th is her birthday she
would no but she but she will be she
before that she will be 35 by
inauguration day and they pointed out
when Biden got elected to stay P stay
out of politics I've talked about how I
long for the Donald Trump speakership of
the house how that would be so amazing
but there is a like if anyone who is if
God or the simulation aliens whatever
you believe in could bring about this
like radical libertarian Taylor Swift
Arc where she just starts coming out
being like I don't even understand why
we're engaging these Foreign Wars I'm
going to run for president and then wins
you like that she's about to go on a
global tour right so she has a chance to
really develop her diplomatic skills I
think this is a great idea okay I like
Taylor Swift as our Diplomat I like that
no but like could you imagine just all
of a sudden right like in mid 20124 she
had taking this like very political
libertarian streak and she would have to
marry Travis Kelce then because then it
would be like this this uh blonde pop
star with the football player running
for the White House I don't see any
regime change under her leadership I I
see concerts yeah there's some great
Taylor Swift for president conspiracies
I I I invite everyone to go read
them they are fantastic I will be
reading I just think she's really doing
a service to All fathers in the country
right now giving their daughters a
reason to watch football with them she's
strengthening the family she's doing
everything there's hilarious posting
ones in chat like no I don't care I'm
here for a good time not for a long time
you
know yeah exactly we're speaking into
existence say no I don't think she'll R
for I'm I'm saying if like I could wish
upon a star and it would come true it
would be like Taylor Swift Allon comes
out with very pragmatic and like logical
political stances anti-interventionist
balanced budget responsibility
individualism and then wins do do
leftist girls like Taylor Swift yeah
Everyone likes Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
did a whole thing she crosses the eye
you don't want to people like her the
girls who like Taylor Swift have the
views of Taylor Swift if Taylor Swift
came out right now and said no more
funding I mean look Taylor Swift very
likely could come out because of like a
view and say no funding for Israel and
then you'd get every 15-year-old girl
being like no my Israel just screaming
at top she said she could do this to us
she could say I don't think we should
invest uh money abroad and all the all
the young girls be like well Taylor said
you know what I like it how the hell did
we get on this like I just I get done
with my show escape this news and I'm
back here I didn't bring this up this is
this is this is not my fault you brought
it up I think I brought it up I don't
even like I can't
escape we're talking the point is these
high-profile leftists are willing to
sabotage their entire careers for their
values they care is not they care more
than the right the right has to care
more people have to get out there and
make themselves vulnerable and just do
it yeah this is crazy I mean this post
from her and then we'll we'll talk about
something else but she's like I don't
know if you've noticed but Israelis from
all over the world love your products
this is from one of the fans and she was
like so remember this says no Israeli
buys from you again anywhere in the
world Gaza doesn't have money to invest
in in my opinion because they prefer to
invest in weapons but have a lovely day
she says I don't Want Blood Money there
you go she's saying listen listen she is
she is she has no problem telling all of
her fans that if you if you are Jewish
if you are Israeli and you are
uninvolved in just a regular civilian
and you decide well Israeli okay and you
decide not to buy a product she doesn't
want your blood money so an Israeli
civilian minding their own business goes
to a store and says well you know I'm
not sure I want this she goes your money
is blood money she's saying the money of
any Israeli civilian is blood Money
pretty pretty harsh she's coming out
with a bold stance you know pretty har
and this and this the left has done this
for ages right there's a lot of people
say if you don't like my politics don't
buy my book don't buy this don't buy
that like they have no problem turning
away customers if they don't believe
that they fall in line ideologically
with them you're right yeah no they'd
rather have the customers that fall in
line with their views they have rabid
rabid followers and and loyal followers
yeah I mean the thing is whether her
makeup Empire career crashes Burns is
sort of irrelevant to me it's more
interesting that would say anything at
all I agree exactly why thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net